like you know when you were a player the
sports gambling Revolution really hadn't
uh kicked off yet and now the NFL's
having to remind players hey if you're
on a team you cannot bet on games right
I've learned a little bit about this
last couple years working with seizures
and and really the the whole just the
topic of conversation has changed that
wasn't a main thing you talked about and
just oh you know society and definitely
something you never talked about in the
locker room uh the locker room is more
about
um you know so hey someone coming up to
me say hey you know what happened
yesterday I'm like what we won you know
21-7 is a great win it's like yeah but
you only got me 12 points for my fantasy
team and they're mad about it so that
Dynamic has changed a little bit and
players obviously have to be you know
they gotta you stay away from it be you
know be very careful seeing it can't be
something that players are getting
involved in